i'm tammy bruce and tonight we put the
biden agenda on trial and indict it
for its far-left failures it's
never-ending stream of incoherent
unintelligible ramblings and total
disconnect from reality
because as it turns out when a dumpster
is on fire for six months
it burns brighter than ever and it
smells pretty bad too
in other words it can't be ignored and
the american people
are taking notice more than ever before
because with no center of gravity
in the white house no strong leadership
and frankly mounting questions
about the stamina and mental acuity of
joe biden confidence
in the future is plummeting as a new abc
ipsos poll has found
that americans optimism in the direction
of the country
has cratered nearly 20 points since may
among democrats and republicans
and a stunning 26 percent among
independents
and that's not all biden is now under
water with independence on
crime gun violence and immigration
add to that at this spike in total
disapproval
on handling covet and the economy
compared
just to march so ask yourself why are
democrats and their unquestioning
left-wing allies
still obsessed with all things donald
trump well
what else do they have to talk about
they don't want to talk about rising
inflation
with the cost of food going up the cost
of lumber going up the cost of used cars
going up the cost of energy going up
they don't want to talk about the
violent crime plaguing america's
communities
we'll have full coverage this week of
more shocking violence caught on tape in
this country
and they don't want to talk about the
ever worsening immigration crisis
created by joe biden we have exclusive
new video
if you thought it was bad before wait
till you see this
and south dakota governor christie gnome
joins us
exclusively tonight from the border you
guys
talking about this biden-made
catastrophe and much more you don't want
to miss that now in all fairness
look joe biden and the democrats are
offering you
a lot their experts are bringing you
job-killing race-baiting economy killing
coveted fear-mongering
far left democrat destruction seemingly
every second
of every hour of every day including
from the failed
dr fauci who's signaling another masked
mandate is coming
we will discuss the actions being taken
to stop the fear-mongering
by tiny tyrants and chef andrew gruel
and i have a few things to say as you
might imagine
about the government's efforts to keep
punching us in the face
while continuing to give the chinese
communist party
a pass because what we've seen from the
biden administration so far
is heavy on sanctimonious condescending
and coercive slaps in the face
at a certain point you have to ask whose
side is joe biden and his administration
on
clearing the way for a russian pipeline
for putin
while destroying a pipeline here at home
fueling racial division in our schools
under the guise of artificial equity a
colluding with big tech oligarchs to
eliminate anyone who dares challenge
the government proclamations taking aim
at the second amendment
and the ability of law-abiding citizens
to defend themselves
undermining sovereignty and relentless
attacks on american patriotism
all while wanting to make everyone hate
each other
as much as these leftists all hate you
and frankly
hate themselves biden and his cabal of
democratic operatives are more concerned
with signaling and cheap talk instead of
actual performance
because solutions mean things will get
better
and that of course undermines the
narrative fueling the grift
and the grift does continue openly and
without care
miranda devine joins me tonight
discussing the new hunter biden
get rich quick scheme helped along by
daddy
self-confidence hard work success
national pride
the left wants you to believe it's all
one big bad thing
failure misery resentment victimhood
hatred for the country
that's what's fueling the left and it's
penetrating nearly every corner of
society so ask yourself
could this shift in attitude and a shift
away from national pride
be present in team usa's stumbling start
at the olympic games for example the u.s
women's national soccer team were shut
out
in their opener with sweden team usa
men's basketball
headed up by a rabid american bashing
leftist greg popovich
got beaten by france the first time in
16 years that they've lost their opener
and it's the first time since 1972 that
the u.s
did not meddle on the first day of the
olympics
and even the star usa gymnastics team
finished second
in qualifying for the first time in over
a decade
one of the few bright spots was men's
swimming which grabbed six medals in
their best olympic start
ever and american fencer lee kiefer made
history with her gold medal
in the individual foil but some have
noted
these american athletes seem more
interested in scoring woke points
than actual ones i contend for some
this is the conscious and subconscious
result of choosing
resentment and grievance over pride and
optimism
translating into an embarrassment
perhaps to even be an american
and to represent our nation the olympics
and sport
are about bringing people together
beyond the issues of the day
there is no unity obviously when team
members are judged as good or evil based
on skin color
just as there's no unity here at home in
the nation itself
if this malignant scheme prevails and
that's exactly
how the left wants it it's time to
reject their premise
we must refuse to behave as though these
far-left con artists
have anything to say that is even worth
a second of your time
they advocate destroying the founding
principles of the country
no one wants that no one yet with the
support of legacy media
corner snake oil salesmen are being
portrayed as new american titans
who cares if that's a lie well we do
certainly
and for goodness sake we must not cede
control of our lives to a completely
bloated corrupt
and incompetent bureaucratic nightmare
made up of a bunch of mediocre
washington tax eaters so we common sense
americans
who want safety and security who want
people and property protected
who want peace and prosperity who want
economic mobility
and who love this great country we are
the majority the super majority
and it's time to start acting on it hey
sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else